president Trump kills the Iran zeal the
West Virginia primary ends Dan
Blankenship's wild hopes and Michael
Cohen could be even more hot water i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
well out a lot a lot a lot of news
breaking yesterday and today and we'll
go through all that first however I want
to say thanks to our sponsor is over at
filter by so when's the last time you
checked the filters in your central air
system
I know sexy stuff now you go home and
you think man what I could really go for
right now is check in my air filters but
here's the problem if you don't you
could not only be breathing a bunch of
gunk you could also be destroying your
HVAC system which could lead to
thousands of dollars in repairs so stop
procrastinating and visit my friends a
filter by America's leading provider of
HVAC filters for home and small
businesses they carry over 600 different
filter sizes even custom ones all
shipped free within 24 hours they're
manufactured right here in the United
States we use them here at the daily
wear offices we use them at the shapiro
household as well filter by offers a
multitude of em e RV options all the way
up to hospital grade so check your
system specifications so you can pick
the right option maximize efficiency and
elevate the quality of the air that you
breathe in they also have an auto
delivery system and that means that you
never need to think about air filters
again so instead he's sitting around and
musing about air filters you just order
them and then they show up when they're
supposed to they show up at your house
and you save 5% so save money save time
and breathe better with filter by com
that's filter bu why.com again filter by
dot-com there's a reason we use it here
at the office there's a reason that I
use it my house filter by dot-com go
check it out right now
okay so the big news from yesterday is
that President Trump has now revoked the
Iran deal and this of course was
supposed to end the world all of human
life would be ended by President Trump
pulling out of one of the crappier deals
of all time we'll go through the Obama
teams wild dismay at all of this I mean
the the crying the sobbing could be
heard for miles around from President
Obama's house in Georgetown and you know
my left is tears tumblr just started
filling up right to the top magically it
just started filling up because of the
leftist years that were happening
because of President Trump revoking the
Iran deal a strong move by President
Trump a correct move by President Trump
here was President Trump what it looked
like yesterday what it sounded like when
he was revoking the Iran deal not only
does the deal fail to halt Iran's
nuclear ambitions but it also fails to
address the regime's development of
ballistic missiles that could deliver
nuclear warheads the Iran deal is
defective
at its core if we do nothing we know
exactly what will happen in just a short
period of time the world's leading state
sponsor of Terror
will be on the cusp of acquiring the
world's most dangerous weapons therefore
I am announcing today that the United
States will withdraw from the Iran
nuclear deal okay so here's the reason
why this is great okay what President
Trump is basically doing is he's saying
listen Iran you can have a nuclear
program or hopes aspirations toward a
nuclear program or you can have an
economy you cannot have both because
what this effectively is going to do is
to snapback sanctions now it's possible
Congress may have to pass new sanctions
but that will happen Congress will pass
new sanctions against Iran already
foreign companies that do business with
Iran are being put in the crosshairs of
the u.s. of the US financial system the
companies like Boeing that have just
signed major contracts with Iran those
contracts are gonna have to be revoked
as well they should be Iran has been
using billions of dollars provided to
them by the United States in order to
pursue terrorism around the world Iran
has been using all that money to build
up its nuclear program there their
missile program more specifically the
nuclear program has sort of been on hold
but they've maintained all of their
technology and they were just going to
relaunch that as soon as the deadline
was up which was going to happen in 2025
anyway so Iran has been they built up
the military I believe 40 percent since
the Iran deal all despite a a massive
decline in their economy well which goes
to show that these were not a bunch of
moderates the lie that we were sold by
the Obama administration is that there
were a bunch of moderates in Iran and if
we could just reach out to those
moderates in the Iranian administration
and if we could give them something like
money if we could just give them money
then maybe they would be emboldened to
make friends with us maybe they would
become friendly maybe they would stop
everything they've been doing with this
nuclear program and this is the lie that
the Obama administration sold it was a
lie it Ben Rhodes admitted as much he
admitted there are no moderates in the
Iranian administration Hassan rouhani is
not a moderate and the fact that the
Obama administration lied about it
allowed the deal to go through
well Oh bomb atoll a bunch of lies about
this yesterday he was very upset because
his Cygnet foreign policy achievement
really his only foreign policy
achievement was this Iran deal and here
is what he said he said the reality is
clear the jcpoa is working that is a
view shared by our European allies
independent experts and the current US
Secretary of Defense the jcpoa that's
the joint joint coalition agreement is
it America's interest in a significantly
rolled back Iran's nuclear program it
has not significantly rolled back around
nuclear program all that has done is put
it on hold briefly while Iran takes all
of that money and builds up all of their
other capabilities Obama made sure that
the Iran deal did not include
restrictions on funding of terrorism or
development of ballistic missile
technology those are the two
technologies that one hooked up to the
bomb boom you have a nuclear weapon and
at least two delivery mechanisms
ballistic missiles and terrorist groups
funded by Iran
Obama then added that some of the
countries of Europe have signed on to
the deal in the belief that the Iranians
can be trusted quote walking away from
the jcpoa turns our back on America's
closest allies an agreement that our
country's leading diplomats scientists
and intelligence professionals
negotiated okay first of all no one
liked the deal when it was signed the
polls showed Americans did not like the
Iran deal when it was signed he could
not get a majority of Congress to
approve his deal this was not a treaty
because he could not get 60 senators to
approve of the jcpoa as for the notion
that the Iran ziyal is abandonment turns
our back on American allies that's kind
of weird because it seems like all of
our allies in the region like our actual
allies in the region are pretty excited
that we're walking away from the deal
here for example it's been through Ben
Netanyahu the Prime Minister of Israel
here is his response to the announcement
Israel fully supports president Trump's
bold decision today to reject the
disastrous nuclear deal with the
terrorist regime in Tehran Israel has
opposed the nuclear deal from the start
because we said that rather than
blocking Iran's path to a bomb the deal
actually paves Iran's path to an entire
arsenal of nuclear bombs and this within
a few years time okay and this of course
is exactly true by the way it's not just
Israel who supports Trump's move here
Saudi Arabia supports Trump's moved here
the UAE supports
Trump's move here Egypt will support
Trump's move here Jordan will support
from smoove here Obama built in
anti-iranian alliance because he was so
Pro Ron this was the unintended
consequence of Obama's foreign policy
from 2007 on Barack Obama was pursuing a
foreign policy he wanted a foreign
policy that made around a regional power
this caused Saudi Arabia and Egypt and
Jordan to look at Israel and say we
might need to make common cause with the
Jews in order to fight off the Iranians
and that's exactly what has happened
hey Obama is still out there defending
the deal of course he says that the
agreement was an agreement between my
administration and the Iranian
government and look at all these other
countries who are mad well how about the
fact that this was an agreement that was
not approved by Congress in the first
place again a free D must be approved by
two-thirds of the Senate okay it is not
something that can be done just because
the president of the United States signs
a piece of paper which is the reason
that Trump could simply come out and rip
up the piece of paper in the first place
hey Obama also argued that the jcpoa had
worked in rolling back Iran's nuclear
program that is not true in the
slightest David Albright is the
president founder of the Institute for
Science and International Security he
told Bloomberg after Israeli
intelligence retrieved a warehouse full
of documents related to the Iranian
nuclear program quote the most
significant thing is that this is a
warehouse collection intended to be used
later for reconstitution they could have
destroyed those documents but these were
being carefully protected and hidden
with the intention to read intention to
reuse them when they launched their
weapons program in other words Iran is
already looking at the possibility of
ramping up their nuclear program and as
soon as this deal was killed as soon as
Trump said the deal was over the
Iranians immediately responded by
suggesting that they were going to
restart their nuclear program and also
fun more terrorism so that sort of gives
the light of the idea these were a bunch
of moderates who had been emboldened by
Trump if they're really moderates if
they're really moderates then what you
would have expected is that Trump kills
the deal they say oh well that's that's
really terrible you know I really think
that we should get rid of our nuclear
program anyway because we're moderate
let's reach out to the Obama
administration to the Trump
administration rather and let's try to
cut a new deal with the Trump
administration and said they said nope
you know what gonna ramp that nuclear
program right back up here was their
actual response because it's clip 13
there's their actual response of Iranian
members of parliament which is a shadow
Parliament doesn't really exist anyway
burning a US flag on the floor of the
Iranian parliament and chanting death to
America in Farsi
and what you're watching here what
you're hearing is the sound of them
trying to use a lighter to light wagon
than they are chanting death to America
the entire Parliament chanting death to
America okay so number one has been Tom
annex points out their garbage with
lighters they just don't know how they
work apparently and then in the Iranian
parliament but second of all these were
the moderates right these are these are
the people in Parliament these were the
people that Obama supposedly wanted to
elevate to power pretty amazing pretty
amazing so you know again these these
are the folks that we were supposed to
trust with all this but Obama thinks
that they are trustworthy he thinks
they're great he says that Iran is
complying with the agreement he says
that the US intelligence community has
continued to find that Iran is meeting
its responsibilities under the deal
again the point being that the deal
itself was so fatally flawed that Iran
could fund Hezbollah around confront
commas around confront al Qaeda Iran
could develop intercontinental ballistic
missiles none of that would have
violated the deal because Obama signed a
garbage deal because Obama was a garbage
president hey finally Obama argues that
the jcpoa does not expire here's here's
just a lie he says the prohibition on
Iran ever obtaining a nuclear weapon is
permanent some of the most important and
intrusive inspections codified by the
jcpoa are permanent even as some
provisions in the jcpoa do become less
strict time this won't happen until 10
15 20 25 years into the deal yeah except
that that's a complete lie everybody
knows that as soon as this deal is up in
ten years which really means in eight
years at this point
Iran was going to rush to build a
nuclear weapon and again they say that
that's exactly what they're going to do
right now it's not just Barack Obama
making these idiotic claims it's also
members of his administration the pod
Taylor the pod saved Tehran crowd is
very upset about all of this all the
people over at positive America I've
invited people from positive America on
this program before by the way they're
not interested well I'm not surprised um
but it's not just it's not just Obama
it's all of his former lackeys who are
very very upset about the cement the
power tweeted she's the former UN
Ambassador she tweeted quote I will
never forget the dark cloud that hung
over the White House in the years Iran
was advancing nuclear program and Obama
was briefed on all the risks of using
military force trump has demolished
America's credibility and paved the way
for Iran to restart its nuclear program
first of all there's this really weird
nostalgia that Samantha power is talking
about where you know there was a dark
and terrible time when Iran was a threat
to the world and then then came the Iran
deal and Iran
you'll solved all the problems okay
let's be real about this for a second
Samantha power as a person who wrote a
book it made her famous all about why
the US could not stand idly by during
genocides
she then presided over Syrian policy
that resulted in the slaughter of half a
million human beings in Syria and she
strengthened the regime that backed the
Syrian regime namely the Iranian regime
so oh how terrible those dead those dark
days when Tehran was a threat around the
silhouette to the world
Iran's been more of a threat to the
world since the jcpoa and they were
before the jcpoa Iran has increased its
development of ballistic missile
technology they've increased their
funding of terrorism they've increased
their military budget they've continued
to back Assad they've taken over Lebanon
they've pushed Hamas into prominence
again they've pushed in Yemen Iranian
Iranian backed parties into power and
yet Samantha power thinks that Trump is
the real problem here then there's Ben
Rhodes the former Obama national
security aide he tweeted quote
one tragicomic element of trumps
presidency is the more he tries to tear
down Obama's legacy the bigger he makes
Obama look first of all Ben Rhodes a
former fiction writer who wrote fiction
on the Iran deal I mean he's the one who
went out and admitted to the American
public that he lied over and over and
over about the Iran deal that so had
Obama talking about moderates in Iran
and a second underplay you the inspiring
words of John Kerry whose face is in a
stage of full-on collapse it's like um
as a former friend of mine used to say
his face looks like it's a mudslide in
the Hollywood Hills well we'll get the
latest from John Kerry in just a second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at wink so if you are a
backer of the Iran deal you need a drink
right now and if you're not a backer of
the Iran deal you also need a drink
right now because hey you know you could
use a drink
pop one open well that's what wink is
for wink WINZ is a great resource they
make enjoying downtime a lot easier
because they make it easy to discover
great wine winks wine experts selected
wines matched your taste personalized
for you shipped right to your door and
starting just 13 bucks a bottle there's
nothing like coming home to a box of
delicious wink wine selected for you it
is the best day of your month people
around the office we had a taste test
here at the office
suffice it to say our employees were
very happy that day fill out Winx palate
profile quiz answer simple questions
that your average store clerk would not
ask or translate into a recommendation
questions like how do you take a coffee
and how do you feel about blueberries
and then they recommend a wine just for
you this is also great if you have to go
to a party and bring a wine and you
don't know the difference between wine
and kool-aid well wint can make sure
that you bring the
a bottle of wine to that party and every
month there are new delicious wines they
have an insanely popular summer water
rose a right now no membership fees you
can skip any month you can cancel
anytime and shipping is covered and if
you don't like about all they send you
they will replace it with a bottle that
you do love no questions asked so
discover great wine today go to try wink
calm / Bend that's t ry winc calm / man
you get 20 bucks off your first shipment
that's try winked calm / man to get 20
bucks off your first shipment again it's
try winked calm / Ben go check it out
he's that / badness they know that we
sent you ok so John Kerry who had been
spending the last couple of weeks
running around the globe trying to gin
up support for this garbage deal he was
very upset yesterday and here he was
ripping into president from John Kerry
reporting for duty what the president
has done by withdrawing unilaterally is
placed the United States in breach of
this agreement he has literally taken a
situation where there was no crisis and
created crisis by transferring to Iran
sanctions that were meant with respect
to the nuclear agreement itself that
what the president has done is
unilaterally broken a multilateral
agreement that was working to prevent a
trance of crap Secretary of State mean
he's just a terrible Secretary of State
Trump had every right to do this you
know why because you and your garbage
administration decided to push this
agreement through without the approval
of the American public or the Congress
end of story
ok Congress has final say on treaties
you decided to go it alone and guess
what that's how it works if you sign the
Executive Order Trump can reverse that
executive order and if you sign an
agreement without the permission of
Congress then Trump can revoke that too
and that's exactly what Trump did
yesterday so good for Trump good for
Trump and John Kerry Bella is one of the
worst secretaries of state in American
history just really an awful Secretary
of State look at the breakdown on the
global stage of America's credibility
Trump restored that credibility
yesterday even finish that credibility
didn't hurt that credibility he helped
restore that credibility in the first
place the reason he helped restore that
credibility is very simple America's
credibility was shot
we had lied to our own people in order
to promote Tehran and now Trump said no
more and you can see the effect of this
okay and I'll show you that you can see
the effect of this here's how okay so
today Mike Pompeo is going to return to
the United States with several detainees
from North Korea and so the what the
line was supposed to be that Donald
Trump was going to blow up the world not
all Trump was going to lead to nuclear
proliferation everywhere Donald Trump
was going to lead to conflagrations that
would consume millions of human beings
and the latest indicator of this was
that he pulled out of the Iran deal and
that North Korea would therefore say
well we can't trust the United States to
keep a deal we signed with them
therefore we must pursue nuclear weapons
right now except that's not what's
happening is it that's not what's
happening in the slightest instead it
turns out that North Korea is trying to
cut a deal with President Trump you know
that crazy president Trump that
threatening President Trump that
President Trump we just pulled out of
the Iran deal and North Korea is now
trying to cut some sort of deal with
President Trump the latest evidence
being that Mike Pompeo the Secretary of
State a good Secretary of State unlike
John Kerry is on his way to North Korea
and he's about expected to return with
three Americans detained in North Korea
a two of the detainees Tony Kim and Kim
hawk song have been held since 2017 the
third detainee dong-chul Kim was
arrested in October 2015 and sentenced
to 10 years in prison with hard labor
for espionage Pompeyo said he'd be
meeting with senior North Korean leaders
he didn't know if he'd be meeting with
Kim he said we're prepared to meet with
anyone who is speaking on behalf of the
North Korean government and can give us
solid answer so we're prepared I do have
to say that the funniest part of this
particular story is that that third
detainee dong-chul Kim he was arrested
in October 2015 and he's presumably been
held in solitary confinement he's been
held away from the world imagine his
reaction when he arrives in the United
States and his met on the tarmac by
President Donald Trump right he has no
idea the Trump is president it's gonna
be amazing
he's gonna get off the plane and Donald
Trump Lee hello I'm the president now
and he's just giving what but that's the
guy who freedom okay that's the guy who
got him free and again this is this is
the entire point all the foreign policy
geniuses all the diplomats he said
Donald Trump is gonna blow up the world
just like George W Bush they're all
Cowboys all these Cowboys the only two
the only the only example in the recent
past maybe it's North Korea now that'd
be the other one the only example in the
recent past of a country voluntarily
giving up its nuclear weapons would be
Libya during the Bushmen
raishin the reason they gave up their
nuclear weapons is because george w bush
invaded iraq and took down saddam
hussein and the American military
destroyed Saddam Hussein's military in
three weeks and Muammar Qaddafi said oh
boy that's scary
what if I just hand over this yellow
cake to you right now and the United
States said all right sure it turns out
that dictators who are scared operate in
ways that are much more conducive to the
American public interest than dictators
who are emboldened do you think the Iran
deal embolden dictators or do you think
that the Iran deal made them more afraid
of American military might do you think
that it made them afraid of America's
commitment or do you think that it made
them seek America's pusillanimous
surrender pretty obvious which is which
because if you were a country pursuing
nuclear weapons you would look at Iran
and say look I'm gonna pursue nuclear
weapons as well because Barack Obama
will sign any deal with me I can make
any lie that I want he will hand me any
amount of money and then in ten years I
can do it I want anyway so why the hell
not
you think that North Korea wouldn't
accept Obama's deal if Obama had put his
deal on the table for North Korea you
think that North Korea wouldn't I said
listen you you lift all the sanctions
you give us hundreds of billions of
dollars and we'll promise well we'll
cross our fingers and hope to die we'll
cross our hearts and hope to die that
will get rid of that nuclear program mr.
president don't worry we'll take care of
it do you think that they wouldn't have
accepted that deal of course they would
have accepted that deal and they would
have been lying they accepted the same
deal from Clinton they accepted the same
deal from george w bush and they would
have accepted it from obama anyway okay
but with trump they don't get to accept
that deal i hope right we hope the
president Trump is a stalwart with
regard to North Korea as he has been
with regard to Iran but it's pretty
clear that North Koreans think that
they're going to have to do something to
please president Trump which is the
reason that they just released three
North Koreans remember I mean three
American citizens from North Korea
remember that's three American citizens
released from North Korea under
President Trump
remember that otto warmbier was killed
in North Korea President Trump was the
president any president Obama was the
president when otto warmbier was taken
into custody in North Korea and he did
nothing zero things none hey I don't
want to be here was given back to the
United States after he was effectively
brain-dead you know only after Trump
took office so clearly there's a bit of
a math change here Trump has changed
something and you know that I'm not a
guy who idly gives credit to President
Trump he gets a lot of credit for
adjusted on the Iran deal and so far
what he's been doing on North Korea it's
showing where's
now I'm still skeptical that something
great comes out of it but we will find
out at least his strategies a lot better
and President Obama's I'm gonna
surrender at the first available
opportunity to anyone who shows adverse
interest to the United States okay
meanwhile last night in West Virginia
there was a primary and that primary in
West Virginia was shall we say amusing
there was a guy named Don Blankenship
and Don Blankenship you shall recall
what was this was this crazed mine owner
who just his probation literally ended
the day of the election so he'd been on
probation the reason he'd been on
probation is because there was a mine
collapse in which he was found negligent
and he had to do prison time so that was
pretty great and and in just a second
I'm going to explain to you how that
West Virginia primary one town first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at policy genius so 80 percents of
people think life insurance costs double
what it actually cost not only that
almost a hundred percent - people think
buying life insurance is a pain in the
butt the truth is a healthy 35 year olds
can get half a million dollars in
coverage for less than 30 bucks a month
and getting life insurance doesn't
actually have to be complicated because
there is policy genius okay
you need to go buy life insurance right
now like there are a lot of terrible
stories about terrible things happening
to people and the family being left
breath because the person who died
didn't bother going to get life
insurance if you're a responsible person
you will right now pause this podcast
pause this show and you will go get your
life insurance from policy genius right
now it's the easy way to compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
they've helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance and placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also do disability insurance renter's
insurance health insurance if you care
about insuring it they can cover it for
you so if you've been thinking about
getting that life insurance go to policy
genius.com it is the easy way to compare
top insurers and find the best policy
for you you'll be saving time money and
hassle and it is indeed free policy
genius.com
policy genius comparing life insurance
does not need to be a pain in the butt
okay so as I mentioned the West Virginia
primary happens yesterday and Tom
Blankenship goes down in absolute flames
so Don Blankenship was of course this
mine owner in West Virginia who had cut
in ads suggesting that Mitch McConnell
was in fact cocaine Mitch which would be
amazing if Mitch McConnell ran coke
that is the least effective coke of all
time and just just saying Mitch
McConnell that dudes a turtle
and if you think the Mitch McConnell is
what if that's Mitch McConnell on a high
I'd really hate I mean he he'd be dead
right I mean then the answer would be
that without cocaine he'd be dead if
you're really cocaine Mitch but in any
case Don Blankenship had called him
cocaine Mitch and then he had suggested
that McConnell's campaign was funded by
China people which was great and there
was a debate in which Blankenship
apparently did pretty well and there are
a couple of polls that were leaked to
the press now the problem was the polls
leaked to the press about Blankenship
didn't have any underlying details so
it's quite possible there was
Blankenship rivals in the race who are
leaking those pulls out in order to
drive down Blankenship's numbers saying
okay well Blankenship might win that
means everybody has to show up because
Blankenship is a crazy person when a
Blankenship got blown out by
double-digits he finnish for about 20
percent of the vote and this led Mitch
McConnell to actually tweet out it was
pretty funny to actually tweet this out
thanks for playing Don and it's a
picture of Mitch McConnell surrounded by
cocaine to understand this joke you have
to have seen the show narcos on netflix
because here's the actual poster for the
show narcos on netflix so narcos is
about the distribution of cocaine by
pablo escobar so they just Photoshop
Mitch McConnell into Pablo Escobar's
body basically the slogan for narcos by
the ways there's no business like blow
business so Mitch McConnell trolling Don
Blankenship now is it appropriate for
Mitch McConnell to do that probably not
is it funny yeah it's kind of funny and
again I can't blame Mitch McConnell too
much since since Don Blankenship had
suggested that Mitch McConnell's wife
was a China person I don't even know
what that means but there are a couple
of instructive things about about the
Blankenship race okay so number one
Blankenship lost for a couple of reasons
one is clearly not but also it is true
that Blankenship had no shot of winning
in a general election now people said
the same thing about Roy Moore but the
truth is that sons the allegations about
Roy Moore in Alabama of going after
fourteen-year-old girls
Roy Moore would've won that race walking
away despite all of his toxic views
despite all of the things that he had
said in the past Don Blankenship it was
pretty clear that he wasn't going
anywhere
Roy Moore probably was going somewhere
if it not been for that late-breaking
scandal you know so it is so Blankenship
let's put this way the Republican
primary voter has not suddenly
rediscovered moderation or sober
republicanism
it's just that the Republican primary
voters still understands that there are
some
candidates who are bound to lose because
they're just too crazy for school okay
Roy Ward's apparently does not break
that barrier but Don Blankenship did now
what is also hilarious is there's
there's one guy and I have to analyze
what he had to say is West Virginia guy
his relatives died in the Blankenship
mine disaster and he said that he voted
for Don Blankenship anyway why do you
vote for Don Blankenship because this
you had cousins who died in that mind as
a career three of them three of your
cousins died in that mine disaster and
you're gonna vote for Blankenship
exactly I want an honest crook and
that's Blankenship okay so I think
there's a lot to this that I want an
honest crook and that's why I can check
Americans are so cynical about politics
right now that they would rather have
somebody who is obviously a gangster in
a position of power than somebody who
pretends to be genteel and they think is
secretly doing something on the sly
rights they'd rather have somebody who's
just a crook outright then somebody who
they think is is hiding the ball I think
that this is the 2016 election nutshell
I think a lot of people saw that Donald
Trump was Donald Trump they're like okay
at least the guy's an honest crook or at
least Donald Trump is an honest Donald
Trump if not a crook than Donald Trump
Donald Trump like the guy is the guy but
Hillary Clinton you know you don't know
what she's doing behind closed doors
because everything she says is a lie so
honesty authenticity now go a long way
in American politics the question is
whether we've gone so far that utter
cynicism means that nobody even a
sincere decent person running for
political office can be trusted and we
may be on the brink of that we may be at
the point in American politics where
anyone who is decent is seen as
insincere that anyone who is not a crook
is seen as actually a crook in disguise
if that's the case if we really go on
that fire in American politics it's
gonna be very difficult to elect to
anyone of decency ever again and I think
it's a miss Reid I think there are
politicians who are honest I mean off
the top of my head I think Senator Mike
Lee from Utah is an honest guy I think
he's not a crook and I think he's a
sincere guy and I think they're a bunch
of people in Congress like this I don't
think they're all bad folks I think the
lie that everyone in Congress is it is
obviously corrupt and they're all hiding
and they're all and they're all
attempting to to gain personally I don't
think that's true
and the problem with an honest crook is
that an honest crook is still a crook an
honest crook is still gonna screw you
you can trust that they're going to
screw you actually right Bill Clinton
was an honest crook and he did exactly
that
right
happy doing exactly that you know the
widespread feeling of corruption has
some pretty significant impacts on
American politics it also leads to
suspicions where none may be warranted
if you think everybody is corrupt you
know Donald Trump was fond of saying
this during the campaign he used to say
he had this sort of world-weary attitude
toward politics if you've ever seen the
Godfather Part one there's this scene
where Michael Corleone comes back from
Italy and he has he had formally dated
Kay Diane Keaton the worst actress in
human history and he had formally dated
Kay and he comes back and he's having a
conversation with Kay and he's talking
about how he wants her to marry him and
she does but you're a gangster and he
says well okay do you the the Senators
have people she says senators don't have
people killed presidents don't have
people killed and Michael says don't be
so naive Kay okay well you know it's a
good line but it's also not true
senators don't routinely have people
killed okay the reality is that when a
senator does kill someone like Teddy
Kennedy it has pretty significant
impacts on their public life senators do
not have the power to have people killed
governor's generally do not have the
power to have people killed Huey Long
might have been maybe the one exception
but it's not it's not a typical thing in
American politics that that would be
crook Russian gangster politics it is
not true in the United States that you
have to worry about you oppose senator
Kamala Harris in California and there's
gonna be a dead fish on your doorstep
the next day but Donald Trump had this
view of politics the problem is if all
of America has that view of politics
then everybody is going to assume that
there's corruption behind everything and
that actually redounds to Donald Trump's
detriment now that he is a politician
now that he's President of the United
States so as an example Michael Cohen is
Donald Trump's personal lawyer and
they're a bunch of allegations out today
from Michael a vanetti Michael a
vendetta is the lawyer for stormy
Daniels that Donald Trump's personal
lawyer engaged in something deeply
corrupt now I'm gonna tell you the
details there's no evidence that any of
this was actually corrupt there isn't
okay you couldn't you can think that it
was corrupt
you can suspect it was corrupt maybe
further evidence will show that it was
corrupt but everybody immediately jumps
to conclusions that there was corruption
going on even when there is no actual
line connecting the dots so here is what
we know The Daily Beast has now
confirmed that Donald Trump's personal
lawyer Michael Cohen received hundreds
of thousands of dollars from a company
connected to Russian oligarch viktor vet
scott vekselberg okay so this guy is
apparently connected to Vladimir Putin
the allegations were initially made by
Michael a vanetti at stormy Daniels his
lawyer okay so apparently the source
the matter confirmed that there's a
dossier published by a vanetti on
Tuesday evening and here's what it said
vex vekselberg and his cousin mr. Andrew
in traitor routed eight payments to mr.
Cohen through a company called Columbus
Nova LLC beginning in January 2017 and
continuing until at least August 2017
the funds a vanetti suggested may have
been used to reimburse cohen for the
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
payment made to storm eg annuals in
exchange for in silence about an alleged
affair with Trump now that's a dot that
has not been connected okay so they're a
couple of dots here that have not been
connected one is this group Columbus
Nova LLC a Russian front group and -
were they paying Michael Cohen said
Michael Cohen would pay off Donald
Trump's bills right was it a bribe to
Donald Trump essentially from a Russian
source there we have three separate dots
and there are no lines connecting any of
these dots CF dot number one which is
that there was a payment that was made
by a company to Michael Cohen number two
is that that company supposedly had to
do with the Russians and dot number
three is that that money was used to pay
off stormy Daniels but there's no actual
lines connecting these dots right
because the only facts that we do know
is that Michael Cohen got five hundred
thousand dollars from this company
Columbus Nova LLC we don't have any of
the other information confirmed none of
it hey there's a serious ongoing debate
over whether that company actually is a
Russian front group or not because in
traitor was a donor to the RNC in June
2017 and trader donated thirty five
thousand bucks to a joint fundraising
committee for the RNC and Trump's
re-election campaign he also gave a
quarter million bucks to Trump's
inaugural committee so in trader and
Vekselberg have been active participants
in the US technology and media sectors
so here's an example Columbus Nova
technology partners they were the first
and only outside investor in Gawker
Media Columbus also backed the record
label of former Def Jam boss Lyor Cohen
invested in the streaming music pioneer
Rhapsody and put money behind a gig
economy site a genetic risk firm and a
company called tomfoolery incorporated
so there's an actual company okay it's
not just a cutout that is being used by
the Russians and Columbus Nova lawyer
Richard Owens of Latham and Watkins
which is a highly respected law firm
insisted that vekselberg did not have a
controlling interest in the firm quote
reports today that Viktor Vekselberg
used in Columbus Nova as a conduit for
payments to Michael Cohen or false the
claim that Viktor Vekselberg was
involved in or provided any funding for
Columbus Nova's engagement of Michael
Cohen is patently untrue
neither vekselberg nor anyone else
outside of Columbus Nova was involved in
the decision to hire Cohen or provided
funding for his engagement Columbus
Nova's own
website until Tuesday night said that
the company was the US investment
vehicle for the Renova group which has
Vekselberg asset management firm but it
is a US investment vehicle for the
renova group it doesn't mean that they
don't have other money coming in I
decide also noted that in traders a
former director and current member of
the Executive Board of remote of Renova
apparently the page of the site was
removed Wednesday morning so it's
possible that a vanadis theory is
correct
Vekselberg was recently questioned by
federal agents working with robert
muller by the way CNN reported that the
queries involved the oligarchs payments
to Cohen but there's no hard evidence
that this connection has actually been
made yet but because everybody assumes
the worst about everybody in politics
the assumption has to be that Michael
Kahn did something deeply deeply wrong
okay in just a second I'm gonna show how
this also hurts Michael Cohen with
regards to AT&T which is supposedly
paying Michael Cohen as well first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
a legacy box so Mother's Day is coming
up and you're trying to figure out what
to get for your mom so you can get her
flowers which would be great you should
and you should get her chocolates you
should do all those things but I think
that the best gift that you can get for
your parents is preserving their
memories because honestly that sort of
stuff tends to fade into the woodwork it
goes in the garage it gets buried under
piles of crap you know it sits in your
phone but never gets printed out
well this Mother's Day what you can do
is give your mom the gift of legacy box
like in Legacy Box takes all your old
VHS and camcorder for tapes films photos
it converts them into perfectly
preserved digital files so instead of
all this garbage in your garage now you
have it all available on a thumb drive
or a DVD you can access it anytime you
want if there's a fire at your house you
just grab the DVD and you go everybody
has always asked what would you grab in
case of a fire and the answer always is
photo albums well instead of you having
to schlep photo albums out of the house
you've already got the thing right there
on your keychain and all your memories
are right there on your keychain they've
made it simple and safe over at legacy
box you send in your old pictures and
home movies and they put them on a thumb
drive or DVD and then you can sit around
and watch those precious memories flash
across the screen 400,000 families have
used legacy box to create over three
million DVDs filled with countless
special memories so this Mother's Day
you ought to go over to legacy box and
legacy box is offering a one-time chance
only to save 50% at legacy box com /
Manso special Mother's Day deal legacy
box com / Ben for that deal legacy box
calm / man we've used it at the Shapiro
household I preserve some memories for
my parents it's just it is it is so good
I mean there there really is nothing
like
I think in terms of something you can do
for your parents and Mother's Day is a
perfect time to do it so check it out
legacy box comm slash men send all of
your old materials there and they send
you back the DVD or the thumb drive it's
just fantastic okay so am I going before
I go any further on the Michael Cohen
latest first you're gonna have to go
over to Facebook you're gonna have to go
to go over to Daily wire rather so for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show live the rest of Michael Mosley's
show live apparently Michael was on fire
yesterday not because I set him on fire
but apparently because he did a really
good show yesterday so you should go
check it out and by the way you also can
ask Michael questions because the
conversation is coming up on Tuesday May
15th so Michaels gonna sit there for an
hour answer your questions at 2:30 p.m.
Pacific 5:30 p.m. Eastern and I don't
know why you'd think he has answers but
if you think he does then you can go
check it out and you can ask him
questions live but only if you are a
subscriber the way it works is you can
watch it live at YouTube or at Facebook
but you can only ask a question if you
subscribe to ask questions as a
subscriber you go over to daily wire
comm and then you go over to the page
where you would watch a show and you
just type it into the chat box and
Alicia Krause will sit there and curate
the questions and ensure that he has
asked all of your best questions so you
can check that out with the subscription
also you want the annual subscription
you get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels the leftist years hot
or cold tumbler it is cheaper than the
monthly is 99 dollars a year and it is
well worth the price because as I say
after that Iran zeal thing it just fills
up automatically with leftist years I
mean Trump is creating all sorts of them
on a daily basis if you just want to
listen to the show later head over to
iTunes head over to YouTube check us out
leave us a review please subscribe we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say there's a lot of speculation
going on with regard to Michael Kahn and
this payment from a supposed source
according to The Daily Beast
if Michael a vanetti store McDaniels his
lawyer his analysis is correct and the
payments violated federal banking law
then Cohen could be in serious legal
jeopardy they're reportedly concerns in
the president's inner circle that coin
could begin cooperating with
investigators and maybe he would flip on
Trump now what would he have to say
about Trump if he flipped on Trump who
knows I mean the answer is who knows and
there rumors yesterday from New York
magazine that seem not completely
illogical that the story about Eliot
Brody who is the former RNC chair that
Eliot broidy
you recall he was also using Michael
Cohen as a lawyer and the suggestion was
that he had paid off a Playboy Playmate
1.6 million dollars to go get an
abortion he had to resign his slot at
the RNC and he had used Michael Cohen as
the go-between there's a story from New
York Magazine suggesting that maybe it
wasn't actually broidy at all maybe
Brody was taking the fall as a cover-up
for Trump I don't know that that's
supported I don't see any evidence to
support that as of yet but if Cohen
flips that could be a serious problem
but again I don't know that the evidence
is there yet that Cohn was actually paid
off by the Russians to help out Trump or
anything like that or that he did
anything illegal speaking of an other
non illegal activity that is apparently
deeply disturbing to everyone a TNC
confirmed Tuesday evening that it paid
Trump's personal lawyer Michael Cohen in
2017 for quote insights into
understanding the new administration the
payments were revealed in a document
published by Stormy's Daniel's attorney
Mike 1180 Tuesday afternoon a vanetti
alleged that essential consultants a
show company set up by Cohen before the
election to pay Daniels was paid by
several corporations including AT&T at
the time AT&T was seeking government
approval for its acquisition of Time
Warner CNN's parent company a document
released by a vanetti stated that
essential received 200 grand in four
separate payments of 50 grand in late
2017 and early 2018 from AT&T
AT&T said no a central consulting was
one of several firms we engaged in early
2017 to provide insights into
understanding the new administration
they did no legal or lobbying work for
us and the contract ended in December
2017 ok but here is um here is one of
the problems ok so all of this may not
be illegal may turn out that none of
this is illegal that paying Trump's
lawyer to talk to them about what from
thinks is not illegal but it does stink
doesn't it I mean there's something
about this that stinks to high heaven
the AT&T thing to me is more disturbing
than
reports about this firm paying michael
cohen $500,000 until we know more about
the firm and whether it in fact was a
russian front group but eighteen t
handing over two hundred thousand
dollars and apparently that number might
be higher to michael cohen for nothing
better than please advise us on how
president Trump thinks you can buy newt
gingrich's book for $11 like no you
don't need Michael Kony do that this
looks like influence-peddling by Michael
Cohen now does that count formally as
bribery no it doesn't but it is
certainly swampy stuff it is swampy
stuff and it's precisely this sort of
stuff that Trump used to rail against
when he said that he was there to drain
the swamp so Michael Cohen is a swamp
creature President Trump needs to
extricate himself from the swamp as fast
as humanly possible I know that he's
used to operating inside a different
sort of swamp the swamp of New York real
estate where you have to cut deals with
with concrete manufacturers wink wink
nod nod in New Jersey and order get
things done but it is time for Trump to
cut the cord on all these folks
he should have cut the corn on Michael
Cohen a long time ago and the fact that
Michael Cohen was taking a bunch of
money from AT&T while AT&T was under the
scrutiny of the of the Trump
administration does not look good it's
it's it's not a good look for Michael
Kahn again that doesn't mean that
everything here was illegal but it does
mean that there are some stuff here that
should at the very least be somewhat
troubling if you believe in honest open
government that is that is anti swamp
government that would be I think
something to to point out by the way it
is worth noting here that Michael have
an eddy who distributed all this
information not clear where he got the
information he could have violated the
law himself in order to get all of this
information because where the hell did
he get it right did it did have an eddy
get it from the court did he get it from
the did he get it from the prosecutors
was he complicit in a crime in getting
these documents in the first place
everything here is deeply suspicious
okay meanwhile yesterday there's an
article at The New York Times that was I
thought really interesting is an article
by Barry Weiss with whom I'm friendly
she's an opinion columnist at the New
York Times and she of course has been
she's been put under heavy scrutiny
because she happens to be not a lefty so
she is I think you could best describe
her slightly right of center Barry but
that's questionable she might just be
sent her Center but she is anti identity
politics and she is not in favor of
yelling at everyone who disagrees with
her and calling them a racist so she
wrote a piece yesterday about the so
called intellectual dark web the
intellectual dark web is
a group of people people like me Eric
Weinstein jordan peterson sam harris a
bunch of people who you're gonna hear
from in the future dave rubin people
gonna hear from in the future on this
show right our sunday special is the
intellectual dark web people who
disagree about everything
people like Michael Shermer who is a
atheist who's slightly to the right of
Center people like Brett Weinstein who
is an atheist who's all the way to the
left we are all part of this so-called
intellectual dark web the only thing
that unites us is we don't like identity
politics we want to have conversations
with each other we don't want
conversations shut down by calls of
racism sexism bigotry homophobia
we are not racist sexist bigots or
homophobes by the way and we are tired
of all conversation being stifled by
this so Barry wrote a long piece about
this and this was her entire point is
that this intellectual dark web exists
out there again the term was coined by
Eric Eric Weinstein who's a former
Harvard mathematician so this led to
Barry appearing on MSNBC and on MSNBC
she got into a conversation with one of
the guests and this guest happens to be
a professor at Princeton okay this
professor at Princeton is a chair of
African American Studies
he's Eddie Glau jr. and why starts
talking about Barry starts talking about
all the various members of the
intellectual dark web and listen to any
cloud responds you wonder why the
audience for shows like mine shows like
Sam shorts like children's why the
audience is increasing it's because if
you keep calling everyone you disagree
with racially biased and racially
motivated a bunch of people are going to
turn off and they're going to instead
turn to people who are honest about
issues okay so here is Barry and watch
what any cloud says because this is a
great window into the mind of the left
when you talk about Sam Harris and Ben
Shapiro in one sentence I could see the
connection between those two which it
have things something to do with how
they think about race having something
to do with how they think about
diversity in the country and the ways in
which that diversity is talked about
right the way in which they think about
political correctness I could see the
way that identity politics identity
politics is is a phrase that kind of is
a red herring identity politics is just
simply questions of justice right no I
don't think so absolutely so is the
question is it's not how I think it
wouldn't help you think about it then so
if the case
here right here no no I got I got a step
in Eddie you have just made Barry
Weiss's point that you disagree with the
way Barry Weiss views the world so
you're going to help her view the world
more the way you view the world the
entire purpose of the exercise is to
have honest conversations with people
and and and to not question their
morality just are their wisdom just
because they don't view the world
exactly the same way what I was this is
the way that people think who do not
want to have a conversation
they say that identity politics which
says we can judge you by the nature of
your ethnicity by the nature of your
skin color that this is just a question
of justice and anyone who disagrees with
that principle anyone who says that race
is something that should be irrelevant
to the vast majority of discussions that
reason should be the basis of discussion
not experience your personal life
experience anybody who says that is
apparently no anti justice right people
like me and Sam that's what we have in
common is that we're anti justice good
for Joe Scarborough that's exactly right
the reason that the intellectual dark
web is this is because the left has
forced everyone into a box together and
so fine if all the reasonable thinkers
who disagree on everything are gonna
talk with one another that's gonna make
the country better maybe they won't
you know feature us on mainstream media
all that often maybe they just do an
occasional piece in the New York Times
on us maybe we don't all have slots at
MSNBC or CNN but I do think that what's
happening is changing the country and I
think it's making a very very big
difference okay time for some things I
like and some things I hate and then we
will get to a bit of Bible talk renewed
Bible talk yeah okay so things that I
like so well I think it was yesterday I
talked about this awful video of a of a
black dude who was knocking a Jewish kid
it wasn't in Crown Heights I guess it
was in Williamsburg New York it was a
Hasidic kid and the kid had a kind of
odd haircut yet he's kind of close
chavin on top and then he had the side
locks coming down and he was wearing a
yarmulke and the kid may have been three
years old and this black guy was mocking
the kid and I ripped into the black ice
I do this is just inappropriate well
this guy now came out and he has
apologized and he gave what I thought
was a great apology so good for him good
for him when you do something
this is how you apologize the guys known
on Twitter as Kai James and he says in
the video that he's truly sorry for his
actions and he says there's no excuse
for it good for him
this is what this is what it looks like
when you do something wrong and you're
supposed to fix it here is here is Kai
James apologizing I recently posted
online a video of me coming out a little
kid in regards to his haircut off rip my
heart I just want to sincerely apologize
to that young boy and his family I never
meant for anybody to get hurt
or for this to be taking the wrong way
it was just a joke and I'm sorry like
I'm truly sorry like I think about it
every day now like that was really like
I've if it was my little brother you're
right I don't want this to be like a
race thing I have nothing against Jewish
people I have friends that are Jewish my
babysitter growing up was Jewish there's
nothing like I have nothing against
Jewish people that honestly right there
was just in regards to the haircut only
that was my opinion on the haircut I
have nothing against them trust me they
haven't been through too much too much
we've been through as much as they've
been through they've been through worse
I don't have no issues with Jewish
people I respect them a hundred percent
they do what they do they grind they get
they get out they get it but right there
that was just me being real immature
that was one of the most immature videos
I probably ever recorded posted online
okay good for him okay this is what an
apology looks like and that's good and
apology accepted like don't he knows he
wasn't supposed to do that he knows it
was egregious and you got to give a guy
credit when he when he recognizes that
he did something wrong hopefully that's
something we can all take to heart okay
time for a thing I hate
now speaking of egregious behavior
okay people who should apologize the
Denver mayor has a son okay and the
mayor of Denver's son was stopped by a
traffic cop and he did one thing that
you're not supposed to do the son of the
Denver mayor his name is Michael Hancock
and the son is named Jordan Hancock he
starts threatening in Aurora police
officer who stopped him for speeding and
here is what he had to say to the police
officer
[Music]
they say calls the cop in effing bleep
and then he lure a gay person
he says I'm about to get you fired you
effing be bored so here's Mayor
Hancock's office in a statement quote we
addressed this matter with Jordan and
his apologize to the officer well I do
not support nor condone his inexcusable
actions and words during this traffic
stop we love our son dearly and support
him what is that lesson supposed to mean
when we love our son didn't support him
in what calling a cop an F word like a
what okay how about this how about our
son acted like a jerk he apologized as
well he should he's in timeout how about
that
but instead I guess now we have to
defend our kids even when our kids do
garbage things the footage was leaked to
the local television station the Aurora
police didn't release the full video and
they said in a statement we'll be
conducting an internal investigation
into this matter to determine the
circumstances under which the video was
released any member who was found to
have violated departmental policies will
be held accountable so great now the
police are going to investigate the cop
for releasing the video but the kid is
gonna go completely free no problem for
cursing out a cop this way during a
traffic stop for abusing cop his way
just just wonderful yet our standards
aren't dropping at all in this country
okay time for a bit of Bible talk so
I've decided that you know we went
through about six months ago we finished
up going through the entire five books
of Moses partial by partial every week
the the Jews read a portion of the Bible
of the Old Testament and went through
the five books of Moses so I've decided
that it's start it's time to start going
through the prophets and the writings so
we'll start with chapter 1 of the book
of Joshua so as you recall one less we
won last we left our story Moses had
died on top of mountain and the Jews
were about to enter the land of Israel
they were looking for a new leader and
Joshua was appointed by God he of course
was Moses his right-hand man which is
interesting of course because Moses
actually had a couple of sons and they
were passed over God did not actually
choose them because they were not the
tool that God needed at the time so in
but in Joshua 1 7 through 10 all right
Joshua gives a lecture to the to the
Jewish people before they go into the
land he says be strong and very
courageous be careful to obey all the
law my servant Moses gave you do not
turn from it to the right or to the left
that you may be successful wherever you
go keep this book of law always on your
lips meditate on it day and night
you may be careful to do everything
written in it then you will be
prosperous and successful have I not
commanded you be strong and courageous
do not be afraid do not be discouraged
for the Lord your God will be with you
wherever you go and then Joshua orders
the officers of the people go through
the camp and tell the people get your
provisions ready three days from now
you're gonna cross the Jordan here to go
in and take possession of the land your
Lord the Lord your God is giving you for
your own now what's interesting about
this is that everybody always says that
Judaism is a theocracy which is true
virtually every religion okay anytime
you have a religion that is that is also
involved in governance that is a
theocracy technically but this is more
like a constitutional monarchy so the
monarchy in Judaism doesn't arise until
King Simon and King until King Saul
which is significantly later than this
portion of time there's a whole book of
judges in which there's essentially a
rotating cast of leaders who are put
into power but the one thing that is
true and this is true even when there is
a king in Israel is that those people
are held to the standard they're held to
the standard of the Bible right they're
held to God's moral standard so it was
not an absolute dictatorship it was more
of a constitutional monarchy than
anything else and Joshua who was the
leader of the Jewish people there is
held to the same standard the law above
all else okay in that concept of the law
above all else including the power of
the leaders to change the law is a
unique one in the history of Western
civilization and has significant
ramifications all the way down to our
own day when there are people who say
that the law should be shifted to
accommodate particularly powerful people
as opposed to the law ruling people and
not man okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with much more I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright floor
publishing 2018